hallo und willkommen zu heute live am
Freitag dauert er ein Jahr der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine und leider
deutet so gut wie gar nichts darauf hin
dass dieser bald zu Ende gehen könnte
gestern erst hat russlands Präsident
Putin in einer langen Rede an seine
Nationen auf weitere Zeiten des Krieges
eingestimmt aber wie steht eigentlich
die russische Bevölkerung zu diesem
Plänen gibt es dort Widerstand gibt es
Kritik oder nur Zustimmung wie groß sind
diese jeweiligen Parameter damit wollen
wir uns heute beschäftigen gerne auch
mit euren Fragen und Kommentaren per
Mail dann natürlich wieder wie immer
über unsere Social Media Kanäle das wäre
die Alternative und wir sprechen über
dieses Thema mit der russischen
Oppositionspolitikerin einer war und
davor bereits mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler und Russland und
Militärexperten in Nico lange zunächst
aber wollen wir noch auf einen anderen
Aspekt eingehen und der bezieht sich auf
die inzwischen sehr offen ausgefochten
Konflikte innerhalb der russischen
militärstrukturen vor allem die
Söldnertruppe Wagner aber auch andere
kritisieren scharf die Militärführung
mehr dazu von Carsten heckes
unerbittlich feuern russische Soldaten
ihre Raketen ab seit Wochen ohne größere
Geländegewinne im Don Bass zum Jahrestag
des ukrainekriegs wird die Kritik an den
russischen Generälen wieder lauter
Igor gierkin russische Nationalist und
selbst militärisch am donbass-konflikt
2014 beteiligt erwartet keinen Erfolg
unter der aktuellen militärischen
Führung
Russland kann in der aktuellen Situation
nicht gewinnen nicht mit dieser Führung
und diesen Personal nicht ohne neue
Maßnahmen immer nur Wasser ins Feuer zu
schütten wird nicht ausreichen
der Chef der seltenertruppe Wagner jetzt
gehen die priguin geht in seinen
Vorwürfen noch weiter wegen der
angeblichen nachschubblockade wirft er
den Generalstab der Armee über sein
Telegramm Kanal vor es gibt eine direkte
Opposition ein Versuch die Gruppe Wagner
zu zerstören das kommt einem Verrat
gleich
die Antwort des
Verteidigungsministeriums alle
Forderungen der angriffseinheiten würden
erfüllt jegliche Bericht über
Nachschubprobleme sein falsch solche
spaltungsversuche würden nur dem Feind
in die Hand spielen Lobos Moskau auch
für den Mut russischer Soldaten doch
auch das lässt sich in Russland kaum
noch verbergen frische Gräber auf
soldatenfried Höfen und die Trauer von
Soldaten Müttern
heftiger Auseinandersetzungen also
innerhalb der russischen Armee darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit dem Russland und
Militärexperten Nico lange einen schönen
guten Abend
guten Morgen
Herr Lange offener Streit und Vorwürfe
von Verrat innerhalb des russischen
Militärs erwartet man ja so bei
Autokratien ja eigentlich nicht wie
schätzen Sie das ein
gegen
eisern verteidigende Ukrainer in gut
ausgebauten Stellungen ein und außer
sehr hohen russischen Verlusten und ganz
geringen Gelände gewinnen kann Russland
keine militärischen Ziele erreichen und
ich werte die Auseinandersetzung diese
geschildert haben so dass man sich
besser bereits versucht gegenseitig die
Schuhe zu geben also die Gruppe Wagner
beschuldigt das Verteidigungsministerium
Verteidigungsministerium hat ohne ihn
Probleme mit den Wagner und das ist ein
Zeichen des Misserfolgs dass man sich
jetzt darum streitet der Schuld ist also
Misserfolg mit Sicherheit auch ein
Zeichen des misserfolge sind die hohen
Verlustzahlen jedenfalls die die in den
Medien kursieren gibt es da halbwegs
verlässliche Quellen was die Zahlen der
gefallenen angeht die Lage scheint ja
für die russische Seite wahrscheinlich
auch für die ukrainische aber eben auch
für die russische ziemlich dramatisch zu
sein haben Sie da Erkenntnisse
wenn man muss alle Zahlen die von beiden
Seiten offiziell gemeldet werden mit
ganz großer Vorsicht anschauen es gibt
aber ganz gute Quellen in der Open
Source intelligence community und viele
diesen Krieg sehr genau beobachten und
im Moment ist es so Russland seit
einiger Zeit seit einigen Wochen
versucht mit infanteriesturm also mit
Soldaten die man einfach nach vorne
schickt anzugreifen und das führt
natürlich zu extrem hohen Verlusten
mehrere hundert Tote und Verletzte
russische Soldaten jeden Tag während die
Ukraine in ausgebauten Stellungen sich
verschanzen können und deswegen weniger
Verluste haben das ist zumindest in den
letzten Wochen an den Frontabschnitten
wo Russland angreift die Situation nimmt
die Antwort auf die nächste Frage
vielleicht schon ein bisschen vorweg was
sie gerade gesagt haben ich hätte mich
noch mal dafür interessiert ob sie
überrascht dass ich die vermeintlich so
überlegene russische Armee so schwer tut
in bachmut Gelände Gewinne zu erzielen
eine vergleichsweise kleine Stadt
naja die angebliche Überlegenheit und
unendlich große Stärke der russischen
Armee ist ja wohl ganz offensichtlich
ein Mythos da wird immer darüber
gesprochen und da werden viele
historische Vergleiche bemüht die
überhaupt gar nicht zutreffen auf die
aktuelle Situation was wir sehen ist das
Russland nicht in der Lage war diesen
Krieg von Anfang an so zu führen wie
sich das die russischen Militärplaner
dachten und dass man die Hälfte des
eroberten Gebietes bereits wieder zurück
verloren hat und dass man jetzt Probleme
hat überhaupt wieder einen Angriff zu
entwickeln also offensichtlich ist die
russische Armee viel schwächer als der
Mythos und das glauben machen will
vielleicht mal den ein oder anderen
Kommentar unserer Userinnen und User DJ
snay schreibt uns auf Youtube bzw Jens
Eppler regen sich Russen tatsächlich
eher über den mangelnden Erfolg auf als
über den Krieg an sich eine eher
rhetorische Frage und dann schreiben wir
oder bekommen die Frage von
konstrukturismus konstru also man will
wirklich schwer auszusprechen könnte man
Wagner nicht einfach besser bezahlen so
dass er gegen Russland kämpft also wie
weit geht die Söldner Mentalität von
Wagner soweit dann wahrscheinlich doch
nicht
naja also bei den Wagner Söldnern
handelt es sich ja um ein eine private
militärfirma von einem Putin vertrauten
die aus in Kern aus sehr harten
russischen Nationalisten und
putinenanhängern besteht die mit größter
Brutalität Vorgehen und die wagnergruppe
ist ja mal gegründet worden damit man
militärische agieren kann aber so tun
kann als sein dass keine russischen
Streitkräfte also da ist nicht zu
erwarten dass die sich jetzt gegen Putin
stellen was aber passieren kann ist dass
die Gruppe in innenpolitischen
Auseinandersetzungen in Russland noch
eine Rolle spielen wird und das sind ja
vielleicht Vorboten dass wir da sehen
dass man da anfängt sich untereinander
zu streiten die
insgesamt diese Operationen sind
wirklich nicht besonders gut geplant und
es ist ja jetzt mehrfach auch von
Nachschub Problemen geredet worden also
offensichtlich ist auch dieser angeblich
unendliche Nachschub in Russland nicht
mehr so vorhanden man hört auch außerdem
dass bei bestimmten Übungen und
Ausbildung für neue Soldaten Munition
fehlt und man die gar nicht richtig
ausbilden kann also da gibt es
erhebliche Probleme mit dem russischen
Krieg gerade
Jumpy teilt uns seiner Einstellung auch
noch mal oder Einschätzung über Youtube
mit militärisch schafft dass die Ukraine
nur mit der Rückeroberung der Krim halte
ich bei der derzeitigen Situation erst
in zwei Jahren für realistisch wie auch
immer zu eher zu dieser Einschätzung
kommt wir zeigen gleich noch mal das
Gespräch mit einer russischen
Oppositionspolitikerin Herr lange vorher
aber noch mal die Frage an Sie wie
schätzen Sie das Verhältnis der
russischen verhält das Verhältnis der
russischen Gesellschaft derzeit
insgesamt ein wie viel Rückhalt hat
Putin noch innerhalb seiner eigenen
Bevölkerung
ja man hört viel von den Propagandisten
im Fernsehen die jeden Tag Paris und
Berlin und London am liebsten mit
Atomwaffen zerstören wollen und die da
völlig
ausflippen jeden Tag weil ihnen der
Krieg nicht weit genug geht und man hat
die
Ultranationalisten sie haben ja Herrn
Dirk ihn vorhin erwähnt und andere die
ständig die russische Militärführung
kritisieren dass man auf diese Weise den
Krieg nicht gewinnen kann es gibt aus
meiner Sicht aber eine ganz große Masse
in Russland die sich Sorgen macht von
Bürgern und man könnte sagen normalen
Menschen die aber den Mund halten und
das muss man auch verstehen in einer
Diktatur die jetzt seit 20 Jahren
ausgebaut worden ist von Putin die sich
mit Kriegsbeginn noch mal verschärft hat
so am Anfang viele Leute verhaftet
worden sind wo Menschen die ja sogar mit
dem weißen Blatt Papier demonstriert
haben verhaftet worden sind also im
Moment gibt es glaube ich viele die den
Krieg kritisch sehen bis hoch in
politische Kreise die aber Angst haben
den Mund auf zu machen und wenn man
sieht das ständig Leute aus Fenstern
fallen ja gerade schon wieder in der
letzten Woche kann man das auch in
gewisser Weise nachvollziehen dass man
da sich nicht traut sich jetzt kritisch
zu äußern ja das war eine Anspielung auf
Marina yankina bisherige Leiterin im
russischen Verteidigungsministerium die
wurde tot in St Petersburg aufgefunden
nach Medienberichten soll sie aus dem
Fenster gestürzt sein solche und
ähnliche Fälle gab es in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten schon mehrfach wir
werden einiges verlangen von dem was sie
jetzt gerade angesprochen haben auch die
verschiedenen Strömungen und
oppositionsformen in Russland gleich
noch mal intensiver beleuchten auch mit
ihnen danke für den Moment klar ist aber
das in Russland Opposition zu betreiben
eine sehr schwierige und auch
gefährliche Angelegenheit ist eine Frau
die das tut und zwar in Putins
Heimatstadt in St Petersburg ist Anna
kieselova vor dem Gespräch mit ihr
zeigen wir euch ihr Porträt mein Kollege
Pablo sielalai stellt sie und Ihr
Anliegen vor
Putin muss weg so lässt sich der Inhalt
einer Petition zusammenfassen die
mehrere Lokalpolitiker aus St Petersburg
vergangenen September an die staatsdumma
gerichtet haben unter ihnen Anna
kieselowa Abgeordnete in jenem Bezirk in
dem der Präsident einst aufwuchs hier
ein selfie mit ihren Mitstreitern sie
fordern Putin wegen seines Vorgehens in
der Ukraine wegen volksverrats
anzuklagen im Internet unterzeichneten
mehr als 60 weitere Lokalpolitiker ihre
Petition die Antwort der Staatsmacht
ließ nicht lange auf sich warten Polizei
und Justiz gingen gegen mehrere
Unterstützer vor einer der Initiatoren
erzählte dem ZDF auch von handfesten
Drohungen
gewisse Risiken
unter anderem habe ich schon Drohungen
erhalten der Sprecher des
Parlaments in St Petersburg das ist die
zweite Person die zweithöchste Person in
der Stadt hat bereits
erklärt dass er mich verprügeln will
zwei der Initiatoren sind inzwischen im
Ausland einer kieseliova ist in St
Petersburg geblieben trotz aller
Gefahren sie lässt sich den Mund nicht
verbieten
guten Abend Frau kieselhofer
guten Abend sie haben bereits im
vergangenen Jahr einen absetzungsantrag
mit organisierte sich gegen Putin
richtete eine Petition der Vorwurf den
sie gemeinsam mit ihren Mitstreitern
erhoben damals gegen den Präsidenten
lautete erfolgsverrat was ist aus dieser
Petition geworden
das war eigentlich ein Dokument von
unserem Gemeinderat von den Abgeordneten
des Gemeinderates an die staatsuma und
das war unsere Bitte an die Abgeordneten
der staatsuma dass sie sich diese Sache
anschauen Herr jufferde unser Vertreter
hat diesen Brief unterschrieben und an
Staatsform mal geschickt Michael Romano
auf einen Duma Abgeordneter hat ihm dann
geantwortet Herr Romanow ist ein
Abgeordneter der Stadt Sankt Petersburg
und Herr Romano hatte gemeint dass er
Herrchen anzeigen wird für diese
Petition also durchaus auch mit Risiko
was sie da tun sie haben auch im
Vorgespräch gesagt dass sie für ihre
Aktivitäten Sie persönlich bereits eine
Geldstrafe erhalten haben beim nächsten
Mal droht
welche Konsequenzen sehen Sie persönlich
daraus
sie Konsequenzen sind wir Volks ich kann
nicht mehr öffentlich die Handlungen der
Russischen Föderation in der Ukraine
kommentieren wenn ich in Russland
weiterhin bleiben möchte und das möchten
sie haben Sie schon mal darüber
nachgedacht das Land zu verlassen
natürlich
habe ich schon daran gedacht dass ich
das Land verlassen könnte
wir haben nun die folgende Situation
wenn ich in Russland bleibe kann ich die
Handlungen der Russischen Föderation in
Ukraine nicht kommentieren aber wenn ich
im Ausland bin wird das auch nicht
richtig sein
in dieser Sicherheit diese Handlungen zu
kommentieren
aber ich kann sagen auch wenn ich in
Europa bin kann ich diese Sicherheit
wahrscheinlich auch nicht Folie genießen
also das ist auf Deutsch zu sagen ein
Zugzwang
Putin und mal auf den Staatspräsidenten
zu kommen wirkte in seiner Rede gestern
weiter sehr kämpferisch der Klang gar
nichts nach Frieden oder nach
Entgegenkommen gegenüber dem Westen wir
haben sie wie hat ihr Umfeld auf diese
Rede reagiert
natürlich war diese Rede an die
Nomenklatura an die Eliten adressiert
wir gehören nicht dazu meine Umgebung
nicht
er hat nicht erklärt dass er dann
atomknopf aktiviert und das ist schon
gut so natürlich ist es sehr traurig
dass der Abrüstungsvertrag mit Amerika
ausgesetzt wird in Russland gibt es eine
starke
Umweltschutzbewegung und das ist
natürlich gegen unsere Werte dieser
Bewegung
der Titel unserer Sendung heute lautet
ja steht Russland noch hinter Putin wie
würden Sie diese Frage beantworten
gesamtgesellschaftlich gesehen
ich kann natürlich nicht
gesamtgesellschaftlich sagen ich kann
vielleicht erklären wie die Lage in St
Petersburg ist und hier ist die
Situation ziemlich merkwürdig wir
besprechen gar nicht dir speziale
Militäroperation in der Ukraine warum
zu einem aus pragmatischen aus
praktischen Gründen aus
Sicherheitsgründen denn es gibt sehr
viele Geldstrafen es gibt sehr viele
Anzeigen
wenn man etwas Falsches über die
Handlungen der Russischen Föderation
sagt
welche Vorstellungen haben sie von
Russland von ihrem Heimatland welche
Hoffnungen wie sollte sich das Land in
den nächsten Jahren entwickeln
wir haben eine sehr starke
präsidentenrepublik das heißt
die Gewaltenteilung steht unter dem
Präsidenten wir haben keine unabhängige
indikative wir haben keinen unabhängiges
Parlament es gibt keine Gewaltenteilung
nur auf dem Papier alles hängt vom
Präsidenten ab
und alles hängt auch davon ab wer seine
Nachfolger sein wird und welche Weichen
dieser Nachfolger stellen wird
die Regierung adaptiert sich nun an die
Situation es gibt sogenannten grauen
Import und das Leben geht weiter in
Russland momentan klar das Leben geht
weiter aber mit Sicherheit nicht so wie
Sie sich das wünschen würden
wie groß ist ihre Hoffnung dass es bald
besser wird
ich
ich verstehe sehr gut wer lange wir
gebraucht haben um die Konsequenzen nach
dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion zur
überwinden wir haben sehr viel Zeit
gebraucht um ein Mitglied der WTO der
World Trade Organisation zu werden
Jahrzehnte und natürlich verstehe ich
auch wenn wir einen anderen politischen
Kurs und ein anderes Regime haben wird
wird das sehr viel Zeit in Anspruch
nehmen um sich wieder weltweit zu
integrieren 10 bis 15 Jahren
Frau kieseldorfer wir danken sehr
herzlich für das Gespräch wissend dass
das für sie auch nicht ohne Risiko ist
umso größer unser Dank dass Sie sich die
Zeit genommen haben alles Gute für Sie
danke
vielen Dank
und das Gespräch haben wir um 18 Uhr
aufgezeichnet tolle Reaktionen hier auch
bei uns im Netz auf diesen Auftritt von
Frau giselowa Mary Delay auf Youtube
schreibt uns mutiger Anna kiesel-lover
und Buddy liebe Anna schreibt lieber
Anna ich danke Ihnen und wünsche Ihnen
viel Kraft also dem können wir uns wie
gesagt nur anschließen wir waren sehr
froh dass wir sie heute hier bei uns in
der Sendung hatten sprechen wir weiter
mit dem Politikwissenschaftler Nico
lange da ist er Menschen wie Frau
Kieselbach sind ja nicht die Regel
sondern noch muss man sagen die Ausnahme
sehen Sie denn eine Chance dass die
Opposition mit zunehmender Kriegsdauer
auch den zu erwartenden zunehmenden
Kriegsopfern doch an Unterstützung in
der Bevölkerung gewinnt
es ist von uns aus sehr schwer
einzuschätzen viele Russen sind jetzt
seit langem daran gewöhnt unter diesen
totalitären Systemen zu leben und sie
werden an ihren Küchentischen oder da wo
sie in geschützten Räumen sind anders
sprechen als in der Öffentlichkeit und
ich fand das sehr beeindruckend gerade
bei Frau Kiesel jorfer man hat ja sehr
genau gemerkt dass sie sehr sehr
vorsichtig formuliert und genau
aufpassen muss was sie sagt und es ist
wichtig dass solche Stimmen nach außen
kommen und gleichzeitig auch bedrücken
zu sehen wie eingeschüchtert die
Menschen mittlerweile in Russland sind
das ist bedrückend in der Tat Franka
leven schreibt uns auf facebook selbst
wenn Putin nicht mehr im Amt ist
existiert immer noch die alles
bestimmende Oligarchie das wäre dann
wieder der Punkt den auf Frau
kieseldorfer angesprochen hat es ist
eben auch die Frage was danach kommt wer
danach kommt
besteht denn andererseits vielleicht
auch die Gefahr dass diejenigen Kräfte
in Russland an Einfluss gewinnen könnten
die einen noch härteres militärisches
Vorgehen vor der denn die gibt es ja nun
auch wie etwa der eingangs schon
gezeigte Chef der wagnergruppe prigoshi
oder auch
Generaloberst kardyroof in den Medien
öfter mal als Putins Bluthund bezeichnet
also wie sehen sie diese Gefahr dass ich
diese Kräfte noch stärker durchsetzen
können
muss man sagen das ist ein Poser der
immer sehr große Worte macht den man
aber glaube ich militärisch jetzt nicht
so stark einschätzen muss der ist eher
dazu da rhetorisch sehr stark zuzupacken
die
russischen Militärs und das russische
die russischen Streitkräfte insgesamt
das was sie gerade machen das ist das
was sie können also ich glaube man
sollte nicht die Vorstellung haben auch
wenn da jetzt jemand anders kommt oder
wenn die jetzt richtig loslegen dann
könnten sie noch viel stärker kämpfen
das Problem das Putin hat ist doch dass
er alles versucht seit einem Jahr dass
er sich aber einfach nicht durchsetzen
kann ganz im Gegenteil er hat Gebiete
wieder zurück verloren auch jetzt diese
Angriffe drohen zu scheitern deswegen
gibt es ja auch die Kritik und er hat
Ruhe Verluste verursacht unter den
Russen er hat ja keiner Rücksicht
genommen auf das einen eigenen Volk bei
diesen Angriffen und kann überhaupt gar
keine Ergebnisse vorweisen das ist ein
Problem wir sollten keine Angst haben
dass der plötzlich noch eine zweite
russische Armee auftaucht oder dass er
plötzlich noch stärker angegriffen wird
wir sehen gerade das was die russische
Armee kann und das ist eben nicht so
stark wie Russland sich das erhofft hat
bleiben wir noch kurz bei dem
militärischen Aspekt der interessiert
unsere ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
immer sehr Norbert Kranz etwa fragt er
wird Wagner bald bedeutungslos sein die
besten Kämpfer gefallen und kein
Nachschub mehr aus den Gefängnissen und
Günther Breitfeld schließt sich an mit
der Frage wie lange kann die russische
Waffenindustrie Equipment liefen liefern
da doch der Verschleiß immens zu sein
scheint also sowohl personell als auch
materiell die Frage nach dem Nachschub
sozusagen wie wie schätzen Sie das ein
die wagnergruppe hat in der Tat jetzt in
den letzten Wochen man kann das gar
nicht anders sagen sehr viele ehemalige
Gefängnisinsassen verheizt das hat aber
dazu geführt dass selbst in den
Gefängnissen sich niemand mehr
rekrutieren lassen will die bekommen das
ja mit dass viele nicht zurückkehren und
dass die meisten sterben und die merken
natürlich auch wie die wagnerkräfte mit
den Soldaten bzw den ehemaligen
Gefängnis entlassen umgehen also die
Menschen werden die Menschen Material
behandelt das ist sehr sehr
brutal und unmenschlich der Umgang dort
in den russischen Streitkräften ist das
auch so deswegen versucht sich ja jeder
wie erkannt vor der mobil machen da wird
das Land verlassen da wird versucht zu
bestechen man versucht irgendwie
drumherum zu kommen dass man da
eingezogen wird und Russland hat ja
schon jetzt an den Grenzen neue
Verfahren eingeführt dass man sich da
anmelden muss die Grenze will man hat
eine neue Datenbank auch gebaut damit
nicht mehr das den Leuten gelingt sich
sozusagen vor der mobil machen
das deutet ja alles auf die großen
Probleme hin was die Industrie angeht
ist es so dass die technologischen
Sanktionen die verhängt worden sind auch
von unserer Seite gegenüber Russland
dazu führen dass bestimmte Dinge einfach
nicht mehr produziert werden können weil
man zum Beispiel die Mikrochips nicht
mehr hat oder andere Bauteile aber es
gibt bestimmte Formen von Munition und
von Waffen die kann Russland völlig
selbstständig herstellen und darauf
konzentriert sich Russland ja Moment man
sieht das ja das ist ja so ein bisschen
wie eine Mischung aus erster und zweiter
Weltkrieg was man da bei bachmut und bei
fule da gesehen hat also
Artilleriebeschuss und infanteriekrieg
und das kann Russland glaube ich noch
eine ganze Weile so weiterführen und
versuchen auf diese brutale Weise
weitere Gelände Gewinne zu machen aber
das sind jetzt in ein paar Wochen
manchmal weniger 100 Meter oder ein paar
Kilometer gewesen das ist also nichts
was irgendwie auch nur den Zielen die
Putin formuliert hat für diesen Krieg
näher kommt
danke Herr Lange für den Moment wir
sprechen gleich weiter waren gerade bei
den verschiedenen Gruppen sozusagen dies
in Russland gibt es gibt natürlich auch
noch diejenigen die sich keiner
politischen Richtung klar zuordnen
lassen oder die sich zumindest nicht
dazu bekennen die schweigende
Bevölkerung sozusagen die auch oft stark
religiös beeinflusst ist unsere Russland
Korrespondentin für begann hat sich mit
diesem Phänomen beschäftigt
für das Vaterland in den Krieg ziehen
die russisch-orthodoxe Kirche gibt dafür
ihren Segen allen voran ihr Oberhaupt
Material
wenn ein Mensch in der Ausübung des
Militärdienstes stirbt glauben wir dass
dieses Opfer alle Sünden reinwäscht die
dieser Mensch begangen hat
teilen die Gläubigen kirills Überzeugung
mit dieser Frage fahren wir nach
jaroslavel einige Autostunden von Moskau
entfernt dort ist Alexej seit einem Jahr
Priester für eine Kirche aus Stein fehlt
derzeit das Geld deshalb liest er die
Messen in einem stillgelegten
Eisenbahnwaggon inzwischen ist der für
viele zu einem Ort der Andacht geworden
auszumachen viele Mütter warten jetzt
auf ihre Söhne viele Frauen warten auf
ihre Ehemänner
ich möchte wissen wie Alexa zum Moskauer
Patriarchen steht
wenn wir die Macht vertikale nehmen so
habe ich als unterstellter keine
Möglichkeit die Haltung der oberen zu
kritisieren ich kann meine eigene
Haltung haben aber Kritik nein
die machtvertikale das Werkzeug
russischer Eliten um sich die
Gefolgschaft zu sichern Kritik im Keim
zu ersticken
der Sonntagsgottesdienst ist gut besucht
Julia und Alexej sind regelmäßig hier
mit ihrer sechs Monate alten Tochter wir
kommen ins Gespräch
in Wirklichkeit ist alles anders als im
Fernsehen sie sagten dass unsere Jungs
nicht sterben und jetzt werden sie tot
zurückgebracht
es war nicht nötig einen Krieg zu
beginnen wir müssen diese Konflikte
untereinander lösen
die beiden haben das Gefühl dass die
mächtigen die Zukunft ihrer Tochter aufs
Spiel setzen ohne dass sie Einfluss
darauf nehmen können
wem glauben worauf Vertrauen nach einem
Jahr der sogenannten spezialoperation
sind viele in Russland verunsicherter
denn je ein zermürbtes Volk das den
Krieg verdrängen will so gut es eben
geht
tja den Krieg verdrängen das war der
Bericht von phoebegar der einer
ausführlicheren Reportage im
auslandsjournal entnommen ist zu finden
auch bei uns in der Mediathek das können
wir uns gerade gemeinsam noch mal
anschauen also auf heute.de Politik
auslandsjournal Russland und das große
Schweigen sehr zu empfehlen das ganze
dort wie gesagt noch
ausführlicher wir sprechen weiter mit
Nico lange ja wir haben es gerade gehört
also es wird versucht teilweise
jedenfalls die Wirklichkeit auszublenden
gleichzeitig aber auch war angesprochen
die Macht vertikale in Staat und auch in
Kirche in Russland ja Kritik soll im
Keim erstickt werden inwieweit helfen
Putin diese Strukturen
also helfen dabei dass im Land niemand
gegen ihn etwas unternehmen kann und er
hat jetzt über Jahrzehnte diese
Strukturen aufgebaut die Opposition
entweder umgering lassen ins Gefängnis
gesteckt oder sie ist aus dem Land
geflohen die Russen verhalten sich sehr
passiv aber ich habe auch nicht den
Eindruck man hat ja heute das auch bei
diesen konzertbildern gesehen und
gestern bei der rede ich habe auch nicht
den Eindruck dass sie jetzt begeistert
Putin unterstützen meine Wahrnehmung ist
dass die Russen jetzt abwarten wie die
Sache ausgeht und dass sie eigentlich
genug haben von diesen Krieg sich aber
nicht trauen sich öffentlich kritisch zu
äußern die Situation in der russischen
Gesellschaft ist allerdings so völlig
anders als bei uns dass wir glaube ich
gar nicht nachvollziehen können was das
heißt jeden Tag in so einem totalen
System das auch noch Krieg führt leben
zu müssen und dass die Leute da gerade
jetzt ein bisschen den Kopf runter
nehmen und vorsichtig bleiben das kann
ich ehrlich gesagt nachvollziehen da
würde ich gerne gerade noch mal einhaken
also zum einen im Stadion der Auftritt
der war heute da wirkte das ganze auch
schon relativ bemüht aber auch bereits
gestern schon als er seine Ansprache
gehalten hat vor den russischen Eliten
und manche Beobachter sagten da auch
schon die Damen und Herren hätten schon
mal euphorische gewirkt uns vorsichtig
zu formulieren glauben die größtenteils
noch an Putins Propaganda oder
applaudiert man da einfach aus Angst mit
also die Angst spielt ganz sicher eine
Rolle und auch die
vorsicht also man traut sich nur etwas
zu sagen wenn auch ganz sicher ist dass
einem nicht schlimmes passieren kann und
alle die da gesessen haben bei der Rede
von Putin die achten ja auch gegenseitig
aufeinander und da gibt es auch
Konkurrenzkämpfe zwischen den um den
Einfluss bei Putin oder Werder Zugang
hat deswegen sind die da alle sehr
vorsichtig aber man hat auch gesehen
erscheint jetzt auch niemanden zu haben
der ihn jetzt begeistert unterstützt
oder der völlig überzeugt ist in dem was
gut tut es wirkte so ein bisschen wie
eine Veranstaltung aus einer völlig
alternativen Realität und das konnte man
den Gesichtern entnehmen also die wissen
alle Russland verliert tausende Soldaten
jede Woche in der Ukraine hat riesige
Probleme leidet unter den Sanktionen und
Putin spricht über Bildungsprogramme und
Sozialprogramme als wären nicht also das
konnte man den Gesicht dann glaube ich
sehr deutlich ablesen dass sie irgendwie
fanden die Rede von Putin und die
Realität passen überhaupt gar nicht
zusammen
darüber sprechen wir gleich auch noch
mal Panzer peace stellt uns die Frage
wenn China das kam auch gestern schon
oft wenn China Waffenlieferungen
zustimmen würde was passiert dann
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz ihre
Einschätzung ist ein neues größeres
Thema aber vielleicht ganz kurz dazu
China als Faktor in dieser
Auseinandersetzung wie es ihre ja
Bewertung
ja es gab ja dazu Aussagen des
us-außenministers Toni Blinken der davor
gewarnt hat und der auch hatte Drohung
gegenüber China ausgesprochen hat das
ist allerdings gar nicht so einfach für
China also man kann da denken an
Munition zum Beispiel für die Artillerie
oder Drohnen aber die meisten
chinesischen Waffensysteme die kann man
nicht einfach so nach Russland liefern
und die Russen könnten die dann benutzen
aber klar ist
russland hofft darauf das ist
Unterstützung aus China bekommen nachdem
es Unterstützung bisher nur aus dem Iran
und ein bisschen aus nordkoriert gab
china hat mir aber den Krieg besser
gefunden zu haben als es so außer als
würde Russland gewinnen und jetzt
Russland große Schwierigkeiten hat habe
ich eigentlich auch nicht den Eindruck
dass China jetzt sich mit dem Verlierer
Russland unbedingt assoziieren möchte
hat China da ein eigenes Interesse wenn
ja welches in diesem Konflikt
das China interessiert sich für China
China ist kein Freund von Russland das
glaube ich auch von niemanden mein
Freund im Moment china möchte so langsam
und systematisch sich so aufbauen dass
es nicht nur die ganze Region im
interpazifik sondern möglichst auch auf
der Welt dominieren kann und die Regeln
bestimmen kann und wird versuchen auch
die russlandskrieg gegen die Ukraine in
seinem Sinne auszunutzen also da hat
Russland jetzt auch nicht zu erwarten
dass es da eine Partnerschaft auf
Augenhöhe gibt China wird da ganz brutal
die eigenen Interessen verfolgen und das
will auch wird auch zum Schaden Russland
sein wenn Russland sich zu stark China
ausliefern muss zwei User Fragen können
wir noch mitnehmen könnte Putin fragt
Schock Flyer wann könnte Putin Luca
schenko zum kriegsbeitritt zwingen das
ist der Aspekt Belarus sozusagen und das
andere ist was wäre Putins letztes Ass
im Ärmel das fragt uns ich ja das letzte
daran möchte man eigentlich gar nicht so
gerne denken aber ihre Einschätzung dazu
also vielleicht Belarus und was könnte
Putin schlimmstenfalls noch machen
ja schon seit Kriegsbeginn versucht
Lukaschenko dazu zu bringen mit eigenen
Truppen in diesem Konflikt einzugreifen
und Lukaschenko dreht und windet sich
und findet immer neue Argumente und
Ausreden warum das nicht geht
Lukaschenko weiß dass die belarussischen
Streitkräfte auch die Bilder russischen
Soldaten keinerlei Ambitionen haben
gegen die Ukraine zu kämpfen und auch
wahrscheinlich wenn tatsächlich so ein
Einsatz gehen wir gar nicht ernsthaft
gegen die Ukraine kämpfen würden
deswegen
Lukaschenko balanciert etwas herum er
versucht einerseits Putin die
Unterstützung zu zeigen und andererseits
zu vermeiden dass er seine Truppen aktiv
in diesen Konflikt schicken muss also
ich glaube da ist keine große Gefahr zu
erwarten wir müssen allerdings schärfer
sein Gegenüber
belush zwar nicht mit eigenen Truppen
angreift aber zum Beispiel
luftwaffenbasen Logistik Munition zur
Verfügung stellt und viele der Angriffe
die ja Kriegsverbrechen sind auf die
Ukraine mit Drohnen in zivile Städte
oder mit Raketen mit Marschflugkörpern
die werden ja von Belarus aus
durchgeführt und da ist glaube ich schon
notwendig dass die Europäische Union und
das die internationalen Partner Belarus
auch zeigen dass das Folgen hat das
Belarus sich so an diesem Krieg
beteiligt das glaube ich glaube ich ganz
wichtig und wird manchmal wird manchmal
ein bisschen übersehen beim letzten Ass
im Ärmel von Putin also wir beschäftigen
uns sehr viel damit wir Putin sich fühlt
und wie Putin denkt wir sollten uns sehr
stark damit beschäftigen wie wir die
Ukraine unterstützen können und
vielleicht ist es auch so das Putin kein
Ast mehr im Ärmel hat wenn er verliert
dann verliert er und wenn die Ukraine in
der Lage ist Gebiet zu befreien dann
kann sich die Ukraine durchsetzen und
dann ist das auch der Weg zum Frieden
wir sollten uns jetzt nicht so einen
Mythos aufbauen das tut ihm noch
irgendwas machen kann um den Krieg für
sich entscheiden für sich zu entscheiden
wenn er das machen könnte dann hätte er
das schon getan er hat ja gedacht er
müsste nur drei Tage Krieg führen und
hat jetzt ein großes Problem im Grunde
geschaffen aus dem er gar keinen Ausweg
mehr findet
abschließend noch mal die Frage an Sie
bei der Putin Rede sie hatten es vorhin
auch schon angedeutet da war ja nahezu
es war frappierend also diese nahezu
komplett spiegelverkehrte Wahrnehmung
der Welt des Krieges auch das Verhältnis
ist von von Ursache und Wirkung
wie soll es da überhaupt jemals zu einer
Verständigung kommen geht das mit dem
Putin Regime überhaupt
ja was faszinierend daran ist ist das
Putin gestern
im Grunde Amerika für alles
verantwortlich macht also er beginnt ein
Krieg aber alle anderen sind daran
schuld und Sie haben gerade den Bürger
aus Russland eingeblendet der sagt na
die Realität ist ganz anders als das im
Fernsehen gesagt wird ich finde es
faszinierend das ist aber Leute bei uns
gibt die diese Erzählung von Putin
wiederholen also in Russland scheint
nicht so viele zu geben die da wirklich
dran glauben aber bei uns gibt es einige
die das in der Debatte wiederholen das
ist schon sehr seltsam die
Propaganda schon von Putin dient dazu
den Eindruck von Normalität zu erwecken
und den Eindruck zu erwecken das Leben
in Russland können wir irgendwie
weitergehen die Menschen sehen aber im
Alltag die Folgen dieses Krieges die
sehen auch die Gräber die sie auch hier
gezeigt haben die wissen auch von den
Soldaten die nicht wiederkommen aus
diesem Krieg und es wird jetzt sehr
interessant sein zu beobachten wie diese
dieser Spalt dieser
auch zwischen der tatsächlichen Lage und
dieser alternativen Realität der
russischen Propaganda wie das sich
weiter ausspielt in Russland also da ist
ein gewaltiger Sprengstoff darin den
werden wir und das werden wir weiter
beobachten vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzungen der Politik und Russland
Experte Nico lange war das uns
zugeschaltet aus Berlin Dankeschön einen
schönen Abend
gerne schönen Abend danke sehr ja und
heute haben wir mehr auf die russische
Seite geschaut morgen wird es dann um
die ukrainische gehen wir haben die
Menschen dort den Überfall auf ihr Land
vor einem Jahr wahrgenommen und wie
schaffen sie es bis heute den Glauben an
sich und an Ihr Land nicht zu verlieren
dazu dann mehr morgen euch für heute
vielen Dank für euer Interesse einen
schönen Abend und bis hoffentlich
demnächst macht's gut ciao
[Musik]